have you had your supper yet well many
of us Friday tends to mean efficient
chips for supper well after years of
being on a protected list because of
overfishing the good news is Cod could
be back on the menu what's going on with
me is a Samuel Stone he's a fisheries
officer at the Marine Conservation
Society good evening to you thank you
for giving up your fish and chips for
tonight's view with us let's just take a
closer look at this because good news
for the North Sea Cod today as it's
hauling itself off what's been called
the red list of fish to avoid eating
however having said that the Marine
Conservation Society assesses food
seafood on a traffic light system and
that's on a 1 to 5 rating where one is
the most sustainable and they've raised
the fishery to an Amber rating that for
level 4 recommendation meaning that we
can eat it but only very occasionally in
deed so let's take a look at exactly
what's been going on here lots of charts
lots of things to look at here not seek
odd numbers collapsed in the nineteen
eighties because of overfishing as you
can see there and they're warming of the
North Sea but new EU rules from 2004
have helped unnumber'd recover somewhat
although these are quite technical
shorts like this just tell us exactly
what's going on to explain some of these
acronyms sure thing so you can see
clearly in the 80s that the caches of
norsu Cod really really did decrease
significantly and that extended rider up
until 2006 we can see that the the
spawning stock by m/s so this is the
adult population okay was at a very high
level over two hundred and seventy
thousand tonnes in fact and that whilst
catchers were extremely high seems to
extinct on us let's get them back up for
us but explain to us exactly were
looking at here because yeah it's going
back up towards that one isn't it which
is a good thing exactly so they did they
declined all the way until 2006 when
they hit rock bottom essentially but the
EU measures that you mentioned they
really started to take effect and since
2006 we've seen a steady increase and
just this year was the first year so you
can see this yellow line down
bottom here this is what scientists call
the biomass limit and below this yeah
the population is really in a dangerous
place but and you see the red line above
that that's the precautionary level we
really need the population to be above
that line once we get above that it's in
a healthy or help much healthier state
let's take a little more detailed look
at this because a few more numbers here
look at North Sea Cod so we're hearing
they're not out of hot water just as yet
this shows the degree of overfishing and
the shows us that action does still need
to be taken absolutely
so this chart so FM sy this yellow line
this is the maximum sustainable yield
and this is the proportion of the
population that we can take out every
year whilst not depleting the population
in the long term so that's really the
maximum we should be taking out and you
can see for a very long time we've been
taking out way too much that's why we've
got legislation coming in exactly
exactly so yeah we've had some really
tough measures and they're slowly taking
effect so well North Sea has been under
question where have we been getting our
Cod from well the UK is important rot in
places 116 thousand tons of coal ash in
total the highest imports but any
officials do seem to like I've caught
more than the quarter that came from
Iceland second China interesting it is
interesting most people wouldn't think
we're getting Cod from from China it's a
long way away so in fact a lot of Cod is
caught in the Northeast Atlantic and we
actually ship it off to China it gets
processed and then sent back to us in
various forms and by the time we get it
in that form it's very hard to tell
exactly what fishery it was caught in so
this is a bit of a risk for traceability
and for authenticity indeed and what the
final mentioned the fact that we do have
other fisheries as well which we have to
keep a closer eye on that remain red
listed but terribly good news it's good
to have you with us later joining us is
penny snipe thanks for having me